six months after a missing las vegas
woman was found
dead one of the men connected to her
death is now in police custody
22 year old leslie palacio was murdered
back in august
her body later discovered right near the
valley of fire state park
sasha loftis spoke with leslie's family
tonight and she joins us now live
outside of the clark county detention
center with more on their message
denise and brian jose rangel is at the
clark county detention center tonight
after
months on the run in mexico now i talked
to leslie palacio's family they say
they're relieved
but they won't truly find peace until
both men connected to her death
are behind bars
it's been six months since leslie
palacio's life was suddenly stolen
this is just the beginning of it we need
to find
the main person that killed my sister
her family hasn't given up their pain
propelling a search for the men
connected to her murder a major break in
the case
came just a few weeks ago when one of
those men jose rangel was arrested near
the u.s
mexico border it was a big relief but
you know that's just the beginning we
need to catch the main character
that main character is jose's son eric
rangalibada
the 25 year old accused of killing
leslie
police say he and jose left the country
after dumping her body near valley of
fire state park
back in september officers believe eric
remains on the run in mexico
leslie's mother is still pushing for
answers
as her entire family prays for peace she
didn't deserve
to be like this she didn't deserve it
jose's capture is a step in the right
direction
but those who loved leslie say this
isn't over
they won't rest until justice is served
we're not going to stop until he's eric
is finally caught
jose rangel faces multiple charges
tonight including aiding a felony
offender
and destroying or concealing evidence if
you have any information
as to where eric rongalibara could be
please call metro police
or crime stoppers at 702-385-5555
now reporting live tonight in las vegas
sasha loftis
8 news now